today i'm going to be speaking with
amanda montel who's a linguist also
author of the book cultish the language
of fanaticism and co-host of the podcast
sounds like a cult um amanda great
having you on i really appreciate your
time thank you so much for having me so
we've talked with cult experts sort of
in the context of whether some of the
followers of former president trump are
a cult we've talked with cult experts
about sort of like what pulls people
into cults and how can you get people
out of cults and and the concept of like
a deprogramming and one of the things
that always happens when we talk about
it is i get emails from people saying
only certain people are susceptible to
cults only it would never happen to me
which may be true but there's this idea
that there's something specific and some
people just like they can't be
hypnotized they would never be
susceptible to a cult
is that true is there something about
the types of people that would even fall
prey to cults
sure well i was absolutely one of those
people who thought i would never fall
prey to a cult i grew up with a cult
survivor in the family my dad was forced
to join a cold called cinema when he was
a teenager my parents are research
scientists i grew up in a home of
skepticism and independent thinking i
thought never would i join a fanatical
fringe group or fall prey to the charms
of a charismatic guru um but then very
quickly after researching this book i
found that the mythology surrounding the
type of person who would join a cult a
word that really has no heart and past
definition um those stereotypes aren't
exactly true we tend to think of the
sort of person who'd wind up in a cult
like heaven's gate or the people's
temple aka jonestown as someone
desperate and disturbed intellectually
deficient
but first of all why would a cult want
someone like that why would they want
someone who's liable to break down
quickly they want someone with an
overabundance of idealism and with
resources and privileges and connections
and stars in their eyes someone who
believes that solutions to the world's
most urgent problems are able to be
found and by affiliating with this group
that they can be a part of that change
they want people who aren't going to
quit after things invariably turn sour
um quite soon so um yeah the cult
survivors that i spoke to survivors of
everything from jonestown to soul cycle
um they they didn't fit this mold of the
desperate cult follower they were
actually quite wise and service oriented
you you mentioned soul cycle which i
think is interesting are our cults
necessarily bad in the sense of i mean
some people might say like the peloton
world is sort of cultish crossfit is
another one soul cycle etc
are cults necessarily bad
sure well this is why i decided to title
the book cultish and it's why i often
hedge my language when i talk about this
wide spectrum of culticult like cultish
groups um our reputation that or the
reputation that cults have as inherently
sinister and nefarious is in large part
shaped by the media coverage of major
cult tragedies like jonestown and the
manson family murders before those
events the word cult was not really on
the mainstream cultural radar um and in
fact the earliest forms of this word
didn't even have really negative
meanings at all the word evolved over
time exactly line in line with how our
culture evolved um so at this point the
word cult can really be used depending
on the context to refer to everything
from a group as deadly and destructive
as q anon to a widely followed wellness
brand or soul cycle and that really
reflects something about how fraught our
culture's relationship is with ideas of
community and spirituality and identity
and meaning um but the definition of the
word cult has so much to do with
cultural normativity what separates a
cult from a religion from another kind
of socially accepted group not all cults
that have been
called cults or could be called cults
are inherently criminal or dangerous so
the word cult isn't really enough to uh
identify what particular dangers are on
the table yeah i mean i think it might
be interesting to hear a little more
about evaluating maybe the parameters
you know thinking back to the 2020
democratic primary
i commented on
there seems to be kind of a cult-ish
thing happening around andrew yang for
example who i like and is going to be on
this show next week i was a supporter of
bernie sanders but there was some
cultist if you looked on reddit and
twitter around bernie certainly around
this candidate named tulsi gabbard who
you may or may not be familiar with um
how can what are the parameters we
should sort of be looking at
sure well
in some context certainly in this one i
don't find that it's always useful to um
strive to identify oh this is
definitively occult yeah and thus it is
wildly dangerous but yes it's good to be
aware of certain red flags if you will
that can signify that something is
cultish and in the book i outline what
these red flags sound like rather than
what they look like you know cult
imagery often involves shaved heads and
long robes and um sometimes the cult is
actually a bunch of people in
t-shirts or leggings or you know it
doesn't look like the cult we've been
conditioned to see
so
i i outline many of these linguistic red
flags in the book
and these can include super emotionally
charged us versus them labels when
everybody inside the group is uplifted
with terminology that love bombs them if
you will that makes them feel special
and elite while there are these you know
super loaded terms that lambast
everybody on the outside as
fundamentally inferior in a super black
and white way even just the creation of
a ton of specialized terminology can be
a sign that something cultish is going
on here we all love the feeling of
speaking a secret language um you know
like pig latin on the playground who
didn't love learning that and being able
to talk in a way that other kids
couldn't understand it makes us feel
like we're putting on a uniform if you
will like we're doing something right
even if we're not saying anything that
can't be said in plain english even if
we don't ourselves understand what we're
saying exactly or couldn't define it for
an outsider that specialized terminology
encourages conformity it in some cases
discourages independent thinking and
then there's this phrase that once you
understand it you won't be able to
unhear it um that is often used in
cultish groups it's called a thought
terminating cliche it's a linguistic
technique that all cultish leaders from
jim jones to jeff bezos use and it
describes a sort of stock expression
that's easily memorized easily repeated
and aimed at shutting down independent
thinking or questioning
so thought-terminating cliches also show
up in our everyday lives in the form of
things like well it is what it is or
it's all in god's plan boys will be boys
and q and on it might sound like trust
the plan or well i did my research of
course research to a q an honor doesn't
involve peer-reviewed studies but those
are some examples i as i'm hearing you
lay this out my mind just can't get away
from jordan peterson and um i you know
one of the i'm curious about another
aspect which is whenever i've i've made
criticisms of jordan peterson in the
past a lot of the emails i get are
i am not accurately
criticizing what he really is saying
that there that actually i'm cr i'm only
criticizing what i wrongly believe him
to be saying and that there really is no
true criticism because what he's saying
is different than what i'm saying which
is sort of indefeasible like if i can
never if you're always going to tell me
i'm misunderstanding what he's saying
but you're actually saying sometimes the
difficulty of understanding what's being
said is a feature and not a bug
right um absolutely to use sort of
circular language misleading euphemisms
that can be really disorienting um i
would venture to think that some of his
followers are confused some of the time
but they just have this sort of
unquestioned worshipping um of him and
yeah that completely sounds like a form
of a thought terminating cliche it
sounds not unlike when new agers or
keith renery if those who are familiar
with nexium would dismiss a valid doubt
or or concern as a limiting belief oh
that's just your mind limiting you from
being able to understand yeah or or
that's a suppressive thought from the
church of scientology or there's a lot
of analogies to that so in in the world
of um changing people's minds there's
this idea that just giving people facts
doesn't get them to change their minds
it often kind of makes them plant their
their feet in the sand or dig their head
in the sand whatever metaphor analogy
you want to use yeah um what when it
comes to getting someone out of a cult
particularly the more serious ones that
that are more dangerous i guess we would
say
what what works and what doesn't work it
seems just saying you're in a cult is
not likely to be very effective
yeah yeah so i'm not a deprogrammer or a
mental health counselor this isn't my
expertise actually like shaking people
and snapping them out of it um but yes
from talking to so many experts what i
can more easily say is what's not
effective um as tempting as it is to
look someone in the eye and tell them
you're in a cult you're brainwashed um
those things are not effective that just
works to alienate that person because of
course they think that you're in a cult
and you're brainwashed um brainwashed is
also
really nothing but a metaphor um and is
a term that's often used as a
thought-terming cliche in itself
sometimes just to write off someone as
hopeless and mind controlled so as
tempting as it is to use phrases like
that they're not super effective um and
also if you're talking to like a q an
honor or an anti-vaxxer or a conspiracy
if folks are familiar with that term the
portmanteau of conspiracy theory and
spirituality um if you try to you know
unpack their logic by citing you know
some of these more peer-reviewed studies
or studies from an institution that
they've been led to believe
is
fundamentally flawed or controlled by
this evil cabal of elites they're going
to feel fundamentally misunderstood by
you um so if it feels like safe and
healthy for you to keep this person in
your life i would say you know have
as much or as little of an outside
influence on them as you can just by
existing maybe use the socratic method
to poke holes in their logic via
questions but indeed like facts don't
change people's minds um and so you just
have to hope that they'll come to
reality on their own and eventually come
safe safely home
in terms of the motivation or what can
be appealing about being in cults or
cultish groups
when we think about conspiracy theories
it seems one of the things that's often
appealing to people is that the
conspiracy theory
is a simpler explanation that often
points to more control over what happens
in our lives rather than less where like
if there's random unpredictable horrible
events
that can be a lot scarier than someone
planned this thing and it's just like
this is the person that did it and we
knew it was going to happen they knew it
was going to happen it's just that's
what it is is there an aspect of that
that applies to the attractiveness of
cults
yeah well cult and conspiracy theories
really go hand in hand because they
create that us versus them binary and
they do a lot of simplifying of logic
and of rhetoric um but absolutely i mean
cultishness and conspiratorial belief
these things tend to spike during times
of cultural turbulence and turmoil
that's what we saw in the 60s and 70s
with the vietnam war and the civil
rights movement the kennedy
assassinations people were feeling sort
of existentially high and dry and the
reason why the united states even though
it's a developed country is so religious
compared to other nations that have you
know high life expectancies and high
education levels is in part because we
have so few safety nets social safety
nets that are there to catch us when we
get sick or lose our jobs we're left
feeling very much all on our own in this
culture and so we end up mistrusting
mainstream institutions and turning
toward alternative groups for closure
and answers and security and some of
those groups are relatively harmless or
even positive but there are a lot of
people who are willing to step in and
take advantage of people's
vulnerabilities that's interesting and
so the it seems that a lot of the same
um
emotional circumstances and economic
circumstances that we talk about in
connection with so many different
uh
aspects of society
point in this in this very same
direction it goes back to some of that
underlying structure so to speak
oh absolutely i mean there's a reason
why the united states and cultists tend
to have this pretty consistent
relationship we always have that's
fascinating um the book is cultish the
language of fanaticism we've been
speaking with author of the book amanda
montel who also co-hosts the podcast
sounds like a cult amanda really a
pleasure having you on i appreciate your
time today yeah of course thank you so
much for having me